most of you will know about the
challenges faced by my beloved continent
Africa too many people are poor millions
of girls don't have access to school and
the errands enough jobs for the rapidly
growing population every day 33 thousand
new young people join the search for
employment that's 12 million for 3
million for more jobs in sub-saharan
Africa less than one in four young
people are likely to get words or
salaried work the chances of making a
secure living are even slimmer for poor
and rural young women they cannot afford
an education and they do not have the
same access to wages loans or land as
man this leaves
entire communities trapped in a vicious
cycle of poverty inequality and
hopelessness but I'm not here to narrate
the doom and gloom because we also know
that a youthful population presents an
opportunity to kickstart economic growth
and solve global challenges and in fact
there is a growing movement in Africa of
educated young women was stepping up and
using the power of their network and a
tool we call social interest to uplift
communities and one of the leaders of
the organization behind this movement an
organization that also supported me
through school and I have seen social
interest multiply the impact of our work
social interest is a way to pay back
interest on a loan through service
rather than dollars sharing time and
knowledge through mentoring academic
support business training to others in
need this means the impact of a loan is
fraud not by
but by many through this system we've
been able to help and send more and more
girls to school support them while they
are there help them start business and
ultimately lead in their communities all
while providing funding for the next
generation social interest can be used
to supercharge any movement where the
benefits can be paid forward let me give
you an example this is to my from Rua
Tanzania she tragically lost her father
which was just three years old living a
disabled mother to single hiddenly
raiser any five siblings went to my
completed primary school she was about
to drop out of school and become one of
the 92% of girls in subs are in Africa
that never finished high school instead
she got lucky she got support from a
nonprofit that paid your fees and
capturing school but upon graduating
high school she first a daunting
challenge of what's next
she knew she had to start your own
business to survive and to help your
mother we had tried so hard to keep a in
school by selling here only us as a
stack of corrugated iron she's she had
been saving in the hope of building a
better home for children Tim I also knew
she wouldn't get a loan from a
traditional bank we generally considers
young rural women like her without land
or assess and bankable through a special
group of lending partners
she secured $350 to start a food shop
selling vegetables oil rice tomatoes
onions and beans turn on network members
you have to trainer on basic business
skills like creating a business plan
working out profits marketing keeping
business records and the value of
savings and a business took off she
replayed the original loan within eight
months and then borrowed $2,000 to start
a motorcycle taxi and career business
still mine now owns two motorcycles and
employs
to people and she's been able to
purchase land and build a house and the
business continues to grow from strength
to strength two-mile repaid the interest
in social interest
she paid social interest by providing
mentoring two girls in a local high
school she volunteered weekly as a
learner guide delivering in life skills
and well-being curriculum that helps
children gain the confidence to ask
questions careful and support each other
learn about health and nutrition set
goals and learn how to achieve them - my
says her greatest reward is witnessing
the girls she matters start to believe
in themselves and succeeding these days
- my also trains other lena guides
that's multiplying the number of girls
making it through school and into secure
likelihoods
like she did through her business
profits she has been able to support his
siblings three nieces and nephews and
other children in your community to go
to school she also regularly supports
other network members for example a
young woman studying for a diploma in
community development in the past two
years - my help there with money for
Buster for sanitary pads for thought and
encourage her to keep going to my
expense three hundred and seventy
dollars a year supporting the education
of others that's 17 percent of gross
earnings from a motorcycle business this
is the power of social interest to Mai's
example shows that if you help one girl
not only to go to school but graduates
and start a business she can in turn
make a giant difference in the lives of
others in the community heads to my paid
back interest on her lawn in dollars his
success might have been felt by her and
the immediate family but because she
paid interest as social interest the
impact was felt
by amenties her nieces nephews employees
and so many others around her stoma is
just one example of many today we have
7,000 renegades
likes to my working across Malawi
Tanzania Ghana Zambia and Zimbabwe and
collectively they've helped children do
better in school the girls we work with
are nearly three times less likely to
drop out of school because Nana guys
make home visits when girls say to
attend school to help them back on track
they also work with communities and
district governments to address the
challenges children face including
preventing or annulling child marriages
connecting children facing hunger or
hardship at warm with local support or
running study group so that children who
might be lagging behind in their studies
can get support as one ketchup they act
is trusted sisters friends and guardians
so far nearly 6300 network members if
borrowed close to three million dollars
with their repayment read of those nodes
at consistently above 95 percent under
140,000 members they've invested their
own resources to support and send over
nine hundred thirty seven thousand
children to primary and secondary school
every young woman we work with supports
on average another three children
outside of an immediate family to go to
school or without additional money from
us we are building a powerful force
gaining ever greater momentum as we open
the door for more and more girls to go
to school succeed lead and intend
support thousands more this system
supporting those was excluded to
transform their lives and then step up
for others can work for more than girls
of course you need to get your money
back
if you lend it but instead of demanding
interest in dollars can you consider
using social interest instead for
example could young people pass on the
skills they learned in training colleges
like Michelle who teaches brick-making
in rosin bubbly or Luiza who is training
others on climate smart agriculture in
Malawi or Fatima in Ghana with training
women to help deliver babies where
expectant mothers might not be able to
make it to the local hospital on time
when I was growing up an elder in my
village in rural Zimbabwe once described
the challenges I first in going to
school she said those who harvest many
pumpkins often do not have the clay pots
to cook them in what you meant was that
old or I got the best possible results
in my exams when I finished elementary
school my talent was of no value if my
family could not afford to pay for me to
continue my education well with this
system we are not just providing pots or
making a single meal out of the pumpkins
after all the hundreds of seeds in a
single pumpkin we are saving the seeds
planting them and naturing every one of
them and the result a virtuous cycle of
prosperity equality and what led by
young women because together we are
shaking up the world pamoja to know Asia
that's why Chile for my network motto
together we can thank you
[Applause]